[Music]
hey friends so if I drop the word float
I'm willing to bet that a lot of you out
there do not know what I'm talking about
in the POI World
um and I want to fix that because I've
been noticing more and more lately that
floats are popping up in my own spinning
and I think once I point them out to you
you're going to recognize they're
popping up in a lot of people spinning
too and I also want to follow it from a
video that happened months ago wherein I
was trying to go down to a local Museum
and check out a really fascinating
looking exhibit never got the chance now
the exhibit is going away next month so
I'm going to try and squeeze this one in
and I want you to come along with me for
it Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're are going to be playing
around with floats as well as checking
out a pretty cool Art Exhibit down at
the hirschhorn gallery here in DC but
before we do all that I want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel Johnny Howard
Lane machinsky and Becca becklinen thank
you all so very much for your support
from my work and my mission so I don't
know if you all remember back in the
spring when I recorded a video about
transitions with anti-brids
during that video I was on my way down
to the National Mall to check out the
hershberine gallery because it is
featuring an exhibit by an artist named
kusama called one with eternity that I
mean I'll be real with you checking out
some of the photographs of my friends
that have been there it looks really
really cool and I want to check it out
now unfortunately
I did not get to see it that day because
I got on it too late and they only have
a certain number of passes they have
available to people each day so
the exhibit closes next month I still
haven't seen it so we're going to try
and make that happen today and it is a
very very blustery fall day it must be
said
um colors are looking beautiful out in
the trees
um but it is also quite windy so
hopefully that doesn't Scotch the audio
too much now I am getting a later start
to this day than I would have liked I
was up quite late last night cooking and
baking a friend's birthday is today and
I am bringing him some cookies later in
the evening
um but yeah I'm as I'm doing this I'm
taking off from the house at about 11
A.M and it's a random Thursday so I am
hoping that there are still entry passes
available for today everybody keep your
fingers crossed for me yeah all right so
let's talk some turkey about POI here
shall we
now as soon as I describe what a float
is I am 90 sure that many of you out
there are instantly going to be able to
identify several contexts in which
you've seen it done a float is basically
just taking a pendulum and performing it
in a linear fashion so you know
basically taking the pendulum up and
down in a straight line you've probably
seen this done in stacking exercises
um I first saw it popping up in the work
of Ronan McLaughlin and Yuda imamura
personally
and you know it's one of these classic
things that
has been around for so long that I think
it's just basically kind of part of the
pulley vocabulary at this point but I
never see people talking about them
anymore and you know what I think that's
also kind of a shame because it's a
technique that I personally have been
finding is super useful
um you know it's funny because in
preparing for this video I was trying to
come up with something I could do as I
was going down to the kusama exhibit
and in going through videos of myself
performing for the past few months I
suddenly realized it's like I'm doing
floats all the time but I just never
think of them as floats
wow it's kind of wild how that pops up I
think part of the appeal of floats is
that they work in a kind of
gravity-defying context you know a lot
of what I see Ronan and Yuda doing with
floats is really to take a top stall and
then just make it seem like it is
spiraling into the abyss it's a pretty
cool way of uh kind of bringing some
Dynamics and level changes to POI
spinning and you know I've brought a lot
of the same stuff into my own spinning
and likewise being able to bring the POI
up at certain points and then taking it
into a different trick I think makes for
some really cool Dynamics in itself as
well I think another reason they're kind
of fun is that they're a reminder that
like kind of the essence of poi is that
we're playing with gravity in a lot of
cases when we're just spinning through
our normal tricks you know a lot of
people have told me that they feel like
the POI that I'm spinning almost look
like they're sticks and they find it
very confusing when they finally see
something that makes the tethers you
know go slack or bend and I think one of
those things that's really cool about
floats is that they remind us you know
yes
the POI themselves are flexible and they
are at the behest of gravity so it
becomes a very very interesting reminder
and just how fragile that whole system
happens to be all right and I'm going to
grab a bicycle to head down to the Metro
here
[Music]
[Applause]
now I'm coming up on the Metro it's
about five after 12 and there is not a
soul on the streets
hopefully this bodes well for uh getting
to the museum keep your fingers crossed
for me
[Music]
cool so I'm a couple blocks south of the
museum I'm in Lafont Plaza I think it's
like 12-ish 30 and I'm not gonna lie I'm
kind of wishing that I grabbed a snack
before I left the house so if I get a
choice of when my injury time is I think
I'm looking for something that might
give me a window of time to go grab some
Bunch but we'll see if I have the option
foreign
[Music]
absolutely every sense now let's go get
me fed
[Music]
well I super necessary
I'll send back to the museum
[Music]
foreign
did not have enough time in any of those
individual rooms to even contemplate
whether I could bring my props in which
I couldn't for those of you that are out
there asking that but still a pretty
cool experience if if any of those
Infinity rooms come to an art museum
near you I highly recommend
now let's go take a look at some float
shall we
[Music]
all right then
so I think what I want to do here is I
want to give y'all some examples of
floats in action stuff that you may have
seen before and thought was interesting
and maybe some stuff that you hadn't
realized was making use of floats as a
concept so let's dive in shall we so
first up probably the first float that I
ever saw and got to a point where I'm
just like oh I want to learn that one
basically what this is is it's a pair of
top stalls that are happening off to the
sides and then you just let your hands
drop I want to say that I first saw this
in an old Mel performance video the one
where he is at fires Festival but as I
was doing my research for this video I
realized that it actually pops up in
several other places too most notably
the end of Zan's section in the Arizona
transmission video from back in the day
so likely I got this from several
different places and uh should probably
be said too that the people I got it
from were probably getting it from other
people too next up one that is
definitely in inspired by stuff that I
have seen both Yuda and Ronan do and
this involves just kind of taking a
butterfly going back and forth and
breaking out of it into a single float
this is a great accent that I've
actually been integrating into some
choreo as well as just something that
feels kind of Timeless to me as I look
back on it I've seen Mel do this I've
seen countless others do it as well it
was also this kind of nifty stacking one
that Roni used to do that for my money
kind of feels like an anti-brid in many
ways in fact I think that going back and
forth between this and an anti-brid
would be you know kind of a good
transition and of course it does a whole
lot to define the physical presence of
one of the POI as the other POI is
moving around it and you know now that I
think about it this also does a really
important thing in that it very easily
allows us to switch back and forth
between anti-brit alignment and hands
together alignment a lot of good things
come out of this next up something that
almost kind of splits the difference
between being a linear isolation and a
float I've found that as I play around
with coming and out of horizontal plane
or even coming in and out of a butterfly
there's this lovely thing I can do where
I just drop both of the POI down a
single line and then pull them back up
again to do whatever I want with them
um I don't know I I personally think
that this is a great application of the
idea for no other reason than you know
doing a thing and then reversing it
definitely brings out the gravity
defying aspects of poi big fan and this
final example is honestly the thing that
inspired me to make this video in the
first place it's something I just
recently came up with of playing around
with going from an anti-spin flower to
dropping into what turns out to be a cat
eye now I know what you're going to say
there isn't technically a float in this
but the transition back and forth
between that anti-spin flower and the
cat eye has a lot of float-like
qualities it's once again just kind of
dropping and letting gravity do what
it's going to do it's just a question of
where you're going to redirect that to
right so I hope you all enjoyed going to
a museum with me today and checking out
some cool uses for toy floats and again
now that I have pointed them out I'm
sure you're going to start recognizing
them popping up everywhere and other
people's flow
so maybe if you want to go ahead and
drop me a comment of some particularly
interesting flutes that have jumped out
to you now that you know what to look
for for my money it's still pretty early
in the afternoon it's only about 3 30
and uh right over there behind me is the
Natural History Museum so I think I
might go hang out with some dinosaurs
with what I've got left to this
afternoon
so
um hey if you all would want to go visit
that museum with me leave me a comment
and maybe I'll come up with a video that
I can do during another visit there
[Music]
foreign
thing out of this video please make sure
to like comment share and subscribe to
help other people find it and of course
to help my channel grow this video would
not be possible were it not for the
amazing support of all of these nice
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support if you out there
watching uh would like to become a
supporter and are not currently you can
do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor POI and signing
up you can do that either at the link
down in the description or the card that
just popped up if you are watching on
YouTube there you can get access to a
whole host of awesome rewards and even
better you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out more videos of
me wandering around town and talking
about different POI Concepts because
apparently that is a genre of video I do
now I'm going to go ahead and leave a
link to a playlist of those videos down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you're watching on YouTube the
YouTube algorithm also thinks that you
might like this top video based upon
your past viewing habits so maybe check
that out as well thanks so much for
watching make sure to get outside and
flow this weekend it is a warm one here
and we're not going to get many more of
those this year and I will see you with
a new video soon
peace